all right what we have to refrain from
doing right now is overreacting it's a
one game in a 16-game schedule we're
very disappointed in the lack of
discipline that we showed a loss of
composure that we showed at times and
just overall not doing a good enough job
from a coaching perspective and a player
perspective to get the job done
Freddie kitchens unrecognizable with a
cleanly shaven face but the Browns
unrecognizable Peter from what we
thought they were going to be it's easy
to say don't overreact how can you not
overreact with all the hype around the
Browns and they completely lay an egg
and lose by 30 at home week one what
Baker Mayfield reminded me late in this
game of is a guy he's been compared to a
lot in his life and that's Brett Favre
because late in games if the Green Bay
Packers were down by 17 with four
minutes to go Favre would take chances
that he would not normally take were at
a different time of the game and it was
you know 14 to 14 and that's exactly
what Baker Mayfield it after his first
interception you know when they go down
by 16 I think he felt like okay I'm
gonna take more chances than I would
normally take I do not look at this as a
disastrous game for Baker Mayfield even
though he was the go-to the week in my
column hey three interceptions on three
series in the fourth quarter but I do
say that I don't think that this was a
normal game for the Cleveland Browns
yeah I hear that it was not a normal
game and I added to that you know why
else it wasn't a normal game because he
got a deal with Mike Vrabel and Dean
pees and you know I give Mike flurry a
lot of credit he's been calling this one
all offseason he knew Vrabel mp's would
have something special Mike I watched
the film in this game yesterday they
called every defense in the history of
football ever
deep defensive coverage in the history
of football in this game and you know a
lot of people are gonna go well why
aren't all teams gonna do that against
Cleveland Browns or against any offense
well because not every defensive staff
can coach all these different defenses
that Dean P's and Mike Vrabel know
they're phenomenal that way it's why
Dean piece has been one of the best D
coordinators in football so Baker
Mayfield certainly didn't have a good
day let's not forget though the game was
1513 late in the third quarter and then
the defense lets up the the parting of
the Red Sea screen for a 75 yard
touchdown the Derrick Henry and yes then
Baker Mayfield got a little errant with
some throws but we do got to give credit
to a Titans defense that's built very
similar to New England's defense great
secondary versatile front seven and a
very versatile scheme to go along with
that and we can't forget the Baker
Mayfield is still young and I think he
had some things thrown at him in that
game that you know he's just not as
experienced as some other quarterbacks
who were four or five years or later on
in their career and this is the test for
the Browns moving forward how do you
deal with days like this how do you move
forward after you have that that outcome
that that just was completely shocking
and stunning in light of what everyone
expected going in and if they would lose
Monday night to the Jets and fall to oh
and to how do you deal with that this is
what we don't know about Freddie
kitchens Peter
he never was really groomed to be a head
coach he just kind of fell into the job
and he's gonna have to figure these
things out on the fly well he's gonna
have good advisors because he's probably
given Bill Parcells a call at some point
this week he's coach with other guys who
he's trusted a lot over the years so I'm
sure he's he's picked up the phone at 1
or 2 points in the last 24 hours to try
to figure things out but I'll also make
one other point about the Cleveland
Browns and I said this I said it
throughout the offseason this is a team
that had great expectations on it for
the first time ever how many players on
this team and I'll count two who've
played consistently in big January games
Morgan Burnett the safety and Demetrius
Harris the backup tight end who had that
same role with the Chiefs so
this is a team they are big-game virgins
and now three of the next four weeks
they are America's game they have
primetime games
Sunday night again or Monday night
against the Jets then Sunday night at
home against the Los Angeles Rams and
then in week five Monday night at San
Francisco
how will they bear up to the pressure of
being America's darlings that's what
we're gonna find out
yeah and that's been my concern the
entire offseason Chris and you know
we've talked about if they really didn't
do enough to rein in those expectations
I don't know what they could have done
but they should have done more to get
people to understand this is still a
work in progress yeah but they're not
gonna panic and like again I like what
Freddie kitchen says there I like what
Baker Mayfield says after the game you
know they have to learn how to win
you're right they are virgins they're
young but I still think there's talent
there and belief in that locker room
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports